Democracy-- Seems everybody was doing so well there for a while-- on the move, spreading hope around the world. And now, of course, more and more countries are moving in the other direction.
民主制度——似乎有一阵子大家表现得都还不错——势头良好，向世界传播着希望。而现在，当然了，越来越多的国家正朝着相反的方向发展。
There are strongman leaders doing great-- in Poland, Turkey, Serbia, Brazil, lots of other places. Even in our own country, democracy is feeling shakier. What is it-- 1/3 of all Americans think the results of the last election were invalid?
波兰、土耳其、塞尔维亚、巴西以及许多其他地方的强人领导人表现得都很“出色”。即便是在我们国家，民主也感到更加动摇了。这到底是怎么回事——三分之一的美国人认为上次选举的结果无效？
Hungary had an election last week. Hungary used to be a functioning democracy, but it's gotten less and less so. Once again, this time around, Viktor Orban was named prime minister. He's been prime minister there for the last 12 years. Now, he gets four more-- no term limits over there.
匈牙利上周进行了选举。匈牙利曾经是一个运作正常的民主国家，但现在却越来越不民主了。这一次，维克托·欧尔班再次被任命为总理。他在过去12年里一直担任总理。现在，他又获得了四年任期——那里没有任期限制。
And to give you a sense of just how stacked the deck was in his favor-- like how extreme it was-- during the entire election, the amount of time Orban's opponents got on state television to make their case to voters was exactly five minutes. I mean, like, for the whole election-- you with me here? Tons of coverage for Orban-- all of it positive-- speeches, interviews, analysis for months. For his opponents-- just five minutes.
为了让你了解他在选举中占据了多大的优势——甚至可以说是极其离谱——在整个竞选期间，欧尔班的对手在国家电视台向选民阐述观点的总时间刚好只有五分钟。我是说，整个选举期间总共只有五分钟——你跟得上吗？欧尔班获得了大量的报道，而且全是正面的——长达数月的演讲、采访和分析。而他的对手只有五分钟。
And most of the other TV stations in Hungary followed suit. And the five minutes of the opponents got wasn't even during prime time. It was five minutes on a Wednesday morning for Orban's main opponent-- this guy, Peter Marki-Zay, a newcomer, mayor from a small town.
匈牙利大多数其他电视台也如出一辙。而且这五分钟还不是在黄金时段播出的。这是欧尔班的主要对手——那个叫彼得·马尔基-扎伊的人，一个来自小镇的新人市长——在周三早上获得的五分钟。
Basically, how it went is, two weeks before the election, Marki-Zay went into the TV studio of M1, the state-run news station, sat down at a round table, across from a TV presenter. Hanging between them was an enormous circular timer with a big 5 on it, like a stopwatch.
基本情况是这样的：在选举前两周，马尔基-扎伊走进国有新闻频道M1的电视演播室，坐在圆桌旁，对面是一位电视主持人。在他们之间悬挂着一个巨大的圆形计时器，上面写着一个大大的“5”，像个秒表一样。
Presenter barely finished introducing him before Marki-Zay took a big breath, tilted his head down, like he was a bull charging into the ring, and spoke.
主持人的介绍还没讲完，马尔基-扎伊就深吸了一口气，低下头，像一头冲进斗牛场的公牛一样开始说话。
[SPEAKING HUNGARIAN]
[匈牙利语演讲]
Thank you very much. Thank you very much for giving me the opportunity to speak for five minutes in four years, on behalf of the entire Hungarian opposition, representing some 2 and 1/2 to 3 million people, he says, quickly.
非常感谢。非常感谢给我这个机会，代表整个匈牙利反对派，代表大约250万到300万民众，发表这四年来唯一的五分钟演讲，他快速说道。
The rest of what he says is more kind of familiar politician stuff. My opponent is a hypocrite. He's corrupt. He's lying about my record. I will keep my promises to you. I will curb inflation. I will pay more to teachers and police.
他其余的话都是些老掉牙的政客套话。我的对手是个伪君子。他很腐败。他在我的政绩上撒谎。我会信守对你们的承诺。我会抑制通货膨胀。我会给教师和警察加工资。
He closes with the opposition slogan-- upwards. The camera pans back from Marki-Zay's face, we see the timer click over to zero, time's up for Marki-Zay. Before Marki-Zay's five minutes, the station played an Orban speech from a couple of days earlier that had lasted an hour. After his five minutes was up, they replayed it.
他用反对派的口号做了总结——“向上”。镜头从马尔基-扎伊的脸上拉开，我们看到计时器归零了，马尔基-扎伊的时间到了。在马尔基-扎伊这五分钟之前，电视台播放了一段欧尔班几天前的演讲，时长达一个小时。在他五分钟结束后，他们又重播了一遍。
Giving exactly five minutes on television to the opposition-- it's like it preserves the appearance of democracy. After all, they're opposition parties. They exist. They can say whatever they want. They appear on television.
在电视上给反对派精确的五分钟时间——这就像是为了维持民主的假象。毕竟，他们还是反对党。他们确实存在。他们可以想说什么就说什么。他们确实出现在电视上。
But of course, they don't get a real chance like they would in a real democracy. And one candidate pointed to the absurdity of all that in his five minutes. There's a bunch of parties that ran in this election, and this candidate was from a satirical political party, called the Two-Tailed Dog Party.
但当然，他们并没有像真正民主国家那样获得真正的机会。其中一位候选人在他的五分钟里指出了这一切的荒谬之处。这次选举中有不少政党参加，而这位候选人来自一个名为“双尾狗党”的讽刺政党。
During his five minutes in the middle of his speech, he got a call on his cell phone.
在他的五分钟演讲中途，他的手机响了。
[SPEAKING HUNGARIAN]
[匈牙利语演讲]
[TELEPHONE RINGING]
[电话铃声]
[SPEAKING HUNGARIAN]
[匈牙利语演讲]
Excuse me one second, he tells the audience. It's the missus. And into the phone, he explains, honey, I'm on TV. I told you about this. Even left a note on the fridge.
抱歉打扰一下，他对观众说。是我老婆。然后对着电话解释道，亲爱的，我在电视上呢。我告诉过你的。冰箱上还留了纸条呢。
And he tries to get off, but the call just somehow won't end. There's stuff that she wants him to pick up on the way home-- milk, cottage cheese. He keeps saying, OK, look, got to go. Love you. You hang up. No, you hang up.
他试图挂断，但电话不知怎的挂不掉。妻子想要他回家顺便买点东西——牛奶，白干酪。他一直在说，好了，听着，得挂了。爱你。你挂吧。不，你挂。
[SPEAKING HUNGARIAN]
[匈牙利语演讲]
Then time runs out. He's like, oh, well, we'll have another chance in four years' time, right?
然后时间到了。他耸耸肩说，哦好吧，四年后我们还有机会，对吧？
This year's campaign in Hungary to try to unseat Viktor Orban-- his opponents talked about it like it was their last chance to save democracy. Things have gotten steadily less democratic under 12 years of Orban. If you had four more years, Hungary was going to tip forever into autocracy.
今年匈牙利试图推翻维克托·欧尔班的竞选——他的对手们谈论这场选举时，称这是拯救民主的最后机会。在欧尔班执政的12年里，情况变得越来越不民主。如果再有四年，匈牙利将永远陷入独裁统治。
This was such a real possibility, that the political parties did something they had never done before-- a kind of last gasp, Hail Mary, buzzer beater, "send the rocket to push the asteroid away from the Earth to save humanity" move. And we wanted to witness that close up.
这种可能性如此真实，以至于各政党做了他们以前从未做过的事——一种孤注一掷、绝地反击、压哨进球，“发射火箭把小行星撞离地球以拯救人类”式的举动。我们想近距离见证这一切。
We have that story, and another story of people not going peacefully towards the fate that seems lined up for them. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
我们有这个故事，还有另一个关于人们不甘心接受既定命运的故事。来自芝加哥WBEZ电台，这是《美国生活》节目。我是艾拉·格拉斯。请继续收听。
Act One, The Brothers Harangazo. OK, so one of our producers, Zoe Chace, flew to Hungary, with producer Diane Wu, in the weeks before the big election. Zoe is somebody who has immersed himself in American politics and elections over the years and covered it.
第一幕，哈兰加佐兄弟。好的，我们的一位制片人佐伊·蔡斯，在大选前的几周和制片人戴安·吴一起飞往了匈牙利。佐伊多年来一直沉浸在美国政治和选举中，并对此进行报道。
And to understand what it's like for the opposition in Hungary, Zoe followed two brothers-- one current and one former member of parliament-- both working to defeat Viktor Orban against, as you'll hear, incredible obstacles that we never see in this country. Here's Zoe.
为了理解匈牙利反对派的处境，佐伊追踪了两兄弟——一位现任议员和一位前任议员——他们都在努力击败维克托·欧尔班，正如你将听到的那样，他们面临着我们在本国从未见过的不可思议的障碍。这是佐伊的报道。
I don't know when this started exactly, but lately, Hungary has become a symbol in American politics. Tucker Carlson went over there and interviewed Orban for his show. Tucker praises Orban's hard-line stance against migrants-- not just the border fence Orban built, but the rhetoric, that new Muslim immigrants will de-Christianize Europe.
我不知道这是什么时候开始的，但最近，匈牙利成了美国政治中的一个象征。塔克·卡尔森去那里采访了欧尔班。塔克称赞欧尔班对移民的强硬立场——不仅是欧尔班修建的边境围栏，还有那种言论，即新的穆斯林移民将使欧洲“去基督教化”。
Orban says things like, will Europe remain the continent of the Europeans? The American Conservative magazine is constantly publishing glowing stories about Hungary's, quote-unquote, "pro-family policies." Meanwhile, on the left, there are all these people trying to make Hungary this canary in the coal mine for the collapse of democracy, as though that's where we're headed, too. America is going to become an autocracy.
欧尔班会说这样的话：欧洲还能保持欧洲人的大陆吗？《美国保守派》杂志不断刊登关于匈牙利所谓“亲家庭政策”的溢美之词。与此同时，在左翼阵营，有很多人试图把匈牙利描绘成民主崩溃的警钟，仿佛我们也正朝着那个方向发展。美国将变成一个独裁国家。
I don't buy that, despite how similar some of this stuff sounds between our countries. And one of the reasons I don't is because of what the opposition did in this recent election. It was really different from anything I've ever seen in America.
我不买账，尽管我们两国之间的一些东西听起来很相似。我之所以不买账的原因之一，是因为反对派在最近这次选举中所做的事情。这与我在美国见过的任何事情都非常不同。
I found two people right in the middle of it. They're brothers. First, the elder one, Gabor Harangazo. He's a leftist, a lifelong socialist. He came into parliament in 2010, right when Orban took power.
我找到了处于这一切中心的两个人。他们是兄弟。首先是哥哥，加博尔·哈兰加佐。他是个左派，终身社会主义者。他在2010年进入议会，正好是欧尔班掌权的时候。
And he was miserable, he says, right from the beginning. Orban was radically changing things around with his ruling party, Fidesz. Gabor sighs a lot when he talks about Hungary.
他说，他从一开始就感到很痛苦。欧尔班正用他的执政党青民盟（Fidesz）彻底改变一切。加博尔在谈到匈牙利时经常叹气。
Imagine, the first six months in the Hungarian parliament, I was sick-- physically sick-- because of what I could see that Fidesz has changed the whole country. [SIGHS] It was very bad.
想象一下，在匈牙利议会的前六个月，我病了——身体上病了——因为我能看到青民盟已经改变了整个国家。[叹气] 那真的很糟糕。
Gabor watched as Orban and his Fidesz party took over big parts of the media, forced out all these civil servants, pushed out all these judges, remade key government oversight jobs-- the public prosecutor, the budget counsel-- so that he could stack them with loyalists with long tenures-- basically, just centralizing and consolidating the government in ways that would allow them to maintain a grip on power even if they lost the majority.
加博尔目睹了欧尔班和他的青民盟接管了媒体的大部分，逼走了所有的公务员，赶走了所有的法官，重组了关键的政府监管部门——检察官、预算委员会——这样他就可以用长期任职的亲信填补这些职位——基本上就是以各种方式集中和巩固政府权力，即使他们失去了多数席位也能保持对权力的掌控。
And along the way, Orban made policies lots of Hungarians loved. He increased pensions, gave big tax refunds for families with kids. He won a lot of loyal voters.
一路走来，欧尔班制定了许多匈牙利人喜爱的政策。他增加了养老金，为有孩子的家庭提供了大笔退税。他赢得了许多忠实的选民。
But to Gabor, Hungary was looking less and less like a free country. He'd hear about something, and he'd be like, no, that's too far.
但在加博尔看来，匈牙利看起来越来越不像一个自由国家。他会听到一些消息，然后会说，不，那太过分了。
Oh, it's too much. They wouldn't do it. But they did it.
哦，那太多了。他们不会那样做的。但他们还是做了。
Kicking universities out of the country, the country's biggest newspaper shut down in a day-- in 2020, Gabor and the rest of the opposition started working on a way to get Orban voted out. The idea was get all the biggest political parties to unite against Viktor Orban-- from the socialist to the right wing, and the four parties in between.
将大学赶出该国，全国最大的报纸在一天之内倒闭——2020年，加博尔和反对派的其他成员开始设法将欧尔班选下去。他们的想法是让所有最大的政党联合起来反对维克托·欧尔班——从社会主义者到右翼，以及中间的四个党派。
There was one party that Gabor knew would be the hardest to work with-- Jobbik, a party that had recently had actual fascists in it. When Gabor first joined parliament, Jobbik representatives harassed him from the floor of the parliament, yelling that socialists should be hanged in the public square.
有一个政党加博尔知道是最难合作的——“尤比克党”（Jobbik），一个最近曾有真正法西斯分子的政党。加博尔刚进入议会时，尤比克党的代表在议会大厅里骚扰他，大喊社会主义者应该在广场上被绞死。
When I became a member of the Hungarian parliament, I was seated in the building just next to Jobbik. And they really hated us. There was very, very big hate towards the socialist party from Jobbik.
当我成为匈牙利议员时，我的座位就在尤比克党的隔壁。他们真的非常讨厌我们。尤比克党对社会主义党有着非常、非常强烈的仇恨。
This was part of why he felt so sick trying to function in the parliament. But after 10 years of Orban, things got so bad, Gabor was like, nothing matters but getting rid of Orban. We need a competitive democracy back.
这也是他试图在议会中工作时感到如此恶心的部分原因。但在欧尔班执政10年后，情况变得如此糟糕，加博尔觉得除了赶走欧尔班外什么都不重要了。我们需要恢复一个有竞争力的民主制度。
If the biggest parties get together and put all our voters together, maybe together, it's enough to vote him out. The coalition's name was United for Hungary. This winter, in the run-up to the election, instead of each party nominating their own candidate for prime minister, they united behind just one guy-- Peter Marki-Zay, the guy who only got five minutes on state TV-- and all the parties campaigned for him.
如果最大的政党联合起来，把我们的选民团结在一起，也许加起来就足以把他选下去。这个联盟的名字叫“匈牙利联合”。今年冬天，在选举前夕，他们没有各自提名自己的总理候选人，而是团结在一个人身后——彼得·马尔基-扎伊，那个在国家电视台只获得五分钟时间的人——所有政党都为他竞选。
I had really a lot of problem with Jobbik, and now, we will govern together if everything goes well. So everything changed in these 12 years.
我和尤比克党确实有很多问题，现在如果一切顺利，我们将共同执政。所以这12年里一切都变了。
Imagine if AOC were out here campaigning with Mitch McConnell to get Mitt Romney elected. You'd know things have gotten really bad here for the Democrats to make a compromise like that.
想象一下，如果AOC（亚历山德里娅·奥卡西奥-科尔特斯）出来和米奇·麦康奈尔竞选，好让米特·罗姆尼当选。你就知道民主党在这里为了这种妥协已经变得有多糟糕了。
The day I met Gabor, I stumbled upon him in the midst of something rather amazing-- to me. This was a little more than a month before the election. I found him in his office in an old Communist Party building-- just Gabor and a desk, and a large drum set. He used to be in a band-- a band whose name translates to Fairy Louis Pop Show.
遇见加博尔的那天，我无意中发现他正在做一件对我来说非常了不起的事情。那时距离选举还有一个多月。我在一栋旧共产党大楼的办公室里找到了他——只有加博尔、一张桌子和一套大鼓。他以前在乐队里待过——一个乐队，名字翻译过来叫“仙女路易斯流行秀”。
And he recently bought this set for himself, because he's so stressed out these days. He says he plays every morning. It's a strong contrast to his academicky affect.
他最近给自己买了这套鼓，因为他这些天压力太大了。他说他每天早上都打。这与他学术性的气质形成了鲜明对比。
He had the Google Doc of the opposition's whole platform open on his laptop-- everything they stood for, everything they wanted to change, including a whole new constitution. It was a plan to save Hungary's democracy that six different political parties have had to agree on. It was right there in front of me.
他的笔记本电脑上打开了反对派整个纲领的谷歌文档——他们所主张的一切，他们想要改变的一切，包括一部全新的宪法。这是一项六个不同政党必须达成共识的拯救匈牙利民主的计划。它就在我面前。
And there were some minor amendments for today, and we just finished it. So it's-- that was on my computer. [LAUGHS]
今天还有一些小的修改，我们刚刚完成了。所以这是——那就在我的电脑上。[笑声]
Can we see it? Can you show it to us?
我们能看吗？你能给我们看看吗？
Yeah, it's--
是的，它是——
I can see all the different editors in the doc and the text jumping around.
我可以看到文档中所有不同的编辑者，文字在跳动。
We want a new constitution.
我们要一部新宪法。
He outlines the basic principles of this new constitution. What you might expect from a country's constitution--
他概述了这部新宪法的基本原则。这可能是你对一个国家宪法的期待——
Re-creation of the rule of law, independence of judges, guarantees of basic rights.
重建法治，法官独立，基本权利保障。
OK.
好的。
I think of a constitution as pretty settled-- not like you'd win an election, and get to rewrite the founding document of the country. But when Orban came in with his party, Fidesz, 12 years ago, that's what he did.
我认为宪法是相当固定的——不像你赢了一场选举，就可以重写国家的创始文件。但当欧尔班带着他的青民盟12年前上台时，他就是这么做的。
First, he used Fidesz' 2/3 majority to scrap the rule that you need 4/5 of the parliament to change the constitution. And then, his 2/3 majority voted in a new constitution. The new constitution outlines certain values-- a commitment that Hungary remain Christian, that marriage was between a man and a woman, as examples.
首先，他利用青民盟的三分之二多数席位废除了修改宪法需要议会五分之四多数的规定。然后，他的三分之二多数投票通过了一部新宪法。新宪法概述了某些价值观——比如匈牙利必须保持基督教信仰、婚姻是男女之间的结合等承诺。
Orban and his 2/3 majority then totally remade the judiciary, the constitutional court, in a way that made it subservient to the governing party, Fidesz. Gabor comes across as both tired and excited today, because today is supposedly the last day-- the day they are finishing the plan after overcoming all the disagreements.
欧尔班和他的三分之二多数随后彻底重组了司法机构和宪法法院，使其从属于执政党青民盟。加博尔今天看起来既疲惫又兴奋，因为今天据说是最后一天——在克服了所有分歧后完成计划的日子。
But there's this glitch, a conflict, with Jobbik around the use of this one word that I guess, to be honest, I'd consider fundamental to any constitution if I had to pick one. Jobbik doesn't like this word.
但有一个小插曲，一个冲突，涉及尤比克党对这一个词的使用，坦白说，如果我必须挑选一个词，我会认为这对任何宪法都是根本性的。尤比克党不喜欢这个词。
They don't like to use the word, equality.
他们不喜欢使用“平等”这个词。
So what is the word in Hungarian?
那么这个词在匈牙利语里是什么？
[HUNGARIAN]
[匈牙利语]
OK. They don't like that word?
好的。他们不喜欢那个词？
No. Because it's too leftist. Even not in the gender chapter. When we wrote in the gender chapter that-- it was a title that-- equality between men and women, and they didn't agree with it, so we had to delete this sentence. Because the equality is not supported by them, because we are not the same.
不。因为这太左翼了。甚至在性别章节里也不行。当我们写下性别章节时——标题是“男女平等”，他们不同意，所以我们不得不删除这句话。因为平等是不被他们支持的，因为我们并不相同。
And we couldn't explain them that equality doesn't mean the same. It means that we have equal rights. We need to get equal salaries. And equality is not meaning that the same.
我们无法向他们解释，平等并不意味着相同。它意味着我们有平等的权利。我们需要获得平等的薪水。平等并不意味着一样。
OK, but to be fair, Jobbik has to walk a super careful line. If they seem too left-wing now, their voters will just vote for Fidesz, Orban's party. Gabor and the socialists have to listen to Jobbik. They're the only party that's going to bring in any right-wing voters to this coalition. The coalition needs Jobbik voters.
好吧，但公平地说，尤比克党必须走一条极其谨慎的路线。如果他们现在看起来太左翼，他们的选民就会转投欧尔班的青民盟。加博尔和社会主义者必须听尤比克党的。他们是唯一能为这个联盟带来任何右翼选民的政党。联盟需要尤比克党的选民。
And Jobbik's more tolerable now for socialists. It's easier for him to listen to them. In the last few years, as they've lost voters to Orban's Fidesz, Jobbik has chosen to moderate. I talked with some of them about it. They've gone Jeff Sessions to Jeff Flake.
而且尤比克党现在对社会主义者来说更易于接受。他更容易听他们的话。在过去几年里，由于选民流向了欧尔班的青民盟，尤比克党选择了温和化。我和他们中的一些人谈过这个问题。他们已经从杰夫·塞申斯变成了杰夫·弗莱克。
You could think of today's Jobbik as sort of centrist Republicans. Anti-corruption is their big issue. Gabor called them Never Trumpers to me. Never Orbanists, he said.
你可以把今天的尤比克党看作某种中间派共和党人。反腐败是他们的大议题。加博尔称他们为“永不特朗普主义者”。他说，是“永不欧尔班主义者”。
What does the word, equality, symbolize to the Jobbik voter, that is bad?
“平等”这个词对尤比克党的选民来说象征着什么不好的东西？
OK, mainly two things. One is, they are anti-communist. And in older generation, equality can somehow be connected to communist ideas.
好的，主要是两件事。第一，他们是反共的。在老一辈人中，平等在某种程度上可以与共产主义思想联系起来。
I see.
我明白了。
And that's--
而且那是——
We are all the same. There's something communist about that.
我们都是一样的。那里面有共产主义的东西。
And that's what they really would like to avoid, to be able to say that you are flirting with communist ideas or something like this.
而这正是他们真正想要避免的，被指责在玩弄共产主义思想或类似的东西。
It was a signal, some kind of signal.
这是一个信号，某种信号。
Yes, yes, yes. And the other reason is Fidesz has a very successful campaign against LGBTI rights.
是的，是的，是的。另一个原因是青民盟针对LGBTI权利开展了非常成功的竞选。
Fidesz, Orban's party, the governing party-- they've recently sponsored a referendum on a law to, for one, get rid of any kind of materials that deal with gay stuff in schools. To safeguard Christian values against Western liberalism-- is how Orban puts it.
欧尔班的政党、执政党青民盟——他们最近发起了一项法律公投，一方面是为了在学校中清除任何涉及同性内容的东西。为了捍卫基督教价值观反对西方自由主义——欧尔班是这么说的。
It's a little more hardcore than what Florida is doing here, but similar. Even the same language promoting it, I noticed-- protect our children. The Hungarian version is, stop the gender madness coming from Brussels, home of the EU.
这比佛罗里达州现在的做法更激进一些，但类似。甚至我注意到推广它的用词都是一样的——保护我们的孩子。匈牙利版本是“停止来自布鲁塞尔的性别疯狂”。
The thinking was, all this might appeal to Jobbik's voters also. So the socialists, and everyone else in the opposition, agreed, yeah, let's duck this whole thing by leaving any remotely gay issues out of their platform. And they went with Jobbik's ask and didn't include the word, equality, in the gender chapter.
大家的想法是，这一切可能也会吸引尤比克党的选民。所以，社会主义者和反对派里的其他人同意了，是的，让我们通过在纲领中避开任何遥远的同性话题来躲过这一切。他们顺从了尤比克党的要求，没有在性别章节中包含“平等”这个词。
So that's why-- this is the other reason why they try to take out from all of our papers.
所以这就是为什么——这是他们试图从我们所有文件中删除它的另一个原因。
The word, equality, is a little bit gay.
“平等”这个词有点太同性恋了。
There are nine other issues that they all think are too gay to agree on-- things they're not going to go near-- the obvious ones, like raising taxes, and then esoteric ones, like nuclear power. Remember, the greens are in this coalition.
还有九个其他议题，他们都认为太敏感以至于无法达成一致——他们不会碰的——显而易见的有提高税收，还有像核能这样深奥的问题。别忘了，绿党也在这联盟里。
I just-- I really like this example about equality and the gays, because it's easy to say you want to compromise so everyone can come together to defeat autocracy, but what if that means leaving gay people out of your human rights program? Is that a compromise worth making?
我只是——我真的很喜欢关于平等和同性恋的这个例子，因为说你想妥协让大家团结起来打败独裁很容易，但如果这意味着把同性恋者排除在人权计划之外呢？这是一个值得做的妥协吗？
To me, it shows how afraid they are in Hungary at this moment. You'll see what they give up. In the US, you hear people on the left say how scared they are that Donald Trump will return to power. But they don't seem scared like the people I talk to in Hungary. They don't seem ready to make those kind of compromises, those kind of sacrifices, in order to win conservative voters who might not want to vote for Trump.
对我来说，这显示了匈牙利人此时此刻有多么恐惧。你会看到他们放弃了什么。在美国，你听到左翼人士说他们多么担心唐纳德·特朗普会重返权力。但他们看起来并不像我采访的匈牙利人那样害怕。他们似乎还没准备好为了赢得可能不想投票给特朗普的保守派选民，而做出那种妥协、那种牺牲。
Anyway, the compromises were all hard. And even though Gabor thought they were done, it wasn't until two weeks before the election that the opposition went public with their platform. Gabor felt the clock ticking.
总之，妥协都很难。尽管加博尔认为他们完成了，但直到选举前两周，反对派才公开了他们的纲领。加博尔感到时间在流逝。
These delays were deeply frustrating to him. They gave him a fiddling-while-Rome-burns-type feeling.
这些拖延让他深感沮丧。这让他有一种“尼禄还在弹琴，罗马却在燃烧”的感觉。
Because we think that this is our last-- maybe not the last chance, but if lose this chance, then-- [SIGHS] it can happen that it was the last chance, yes. Of course, the opposition parties could work together for another four years. But-- [SIGHS] I'm afraid that many, many people will lose their faith that change could be any time.
因为我们认为这是我们最后的——也许不是最后的机会，但如果失去这个机会，那么——[叹气] 有可能这就是最后的机会，是的。当然，反对党可以再合作四年。但是——[叹气] 我担心很多人会失去对未来任何改变的信心。
He has relatives who are afraid to say out loud what they think. He says his kids are being taught to hate people who are different from them in school.
他有亲戚害怕大声说出自己的想法。他说他的孩子们在学校里被教导去仇恨与自己不同的人。
It's poisoning. [CHUCKLES]
这是一种毒害。[轻笑]
He wasn't sleeping at night these days, he says, because he was fighting with his wife about leaving. If they lose, she says, they have to leave the country.
他说这些天他晚上睡不着觉，因为他还在和妻子争论要不要离开。她说，如果他们输了，他们就必须离开这个国家。
Yes, I'm not sure that I'm able to leave. [CHUCKLES] Yeah.
是的，我不确定我有能力离开。[轻笑] 是的。
Even If you lose?
即使你输了？
Maybe I will leave with my family because of my family, but not because of, I would like to leave.
也许我会因为我的家人而离开，但不是因为我想离开。
Because you would, what, want to stay and keep fighting?
因为你会，怎么说，想留下来继续战斗？
Mm-hmm.
嗯。
Forming the coalition and keeping the coalition together has been really hard. But the biggest hurdle, I believe-- it's letting voters know what they're even doing.
组建联盟并保持联盟团结真的很困难。但我认为最大的障碍——是让选民知道他们在做什么。
It's like, is a campaign a campaign if no one knows you're campaigning? That challenge-- I didn't really understand how big it was until I hung out with Tamas Harangazo, Gabor's younger brother.
这就像，如果没人知道你在竞选，那还叫竞选吗？那个挑战——直到我和加博尔的弟弟塔马斯·哈兰加佐相处时，我才真正理解它有多大。
He's brasher, louder. Gabor's more stoic. Tamas is jumpier. He's part of the coalition, too. Since the beginning, he's been there with Gabor. He's also a socialist. He's out here trying to win his seat in parliament.
他更粗鲁、声音更大。加博尔更坚忍。塔马斯更容易冲动。他也是联盟的一员。从一开始他就和加博尔在一起。他也是个社会主义者。他在这里努力争取他的议会席位。
I met him in his campaign office, in Szekszard, where the boys grew up. And there were all these things that were both like elections I know, and totally unlike elections I know, at the campaign offices I went to in Hungary.
我在塞克萨尔德的竞选办公室见到了他，那是男孩们长大的地方。而在我去的匈牙利竞选办公室里，所有这些东西既像我知道的选举，又完全不像我知道的选举。
There were campaign managers, maps, schedules, swag with the candidate's name on it, pizza boxes, and pastries, and coffee, and all the things you expect to see exactly in a campaign office. And talking to Tamas, at first, it was what I expect.
有竞选经理、地图、日程表、印有候选人名字的周边、披萨盒、糕点、咖啡，以及你期望在竞选办公室看到的一切。最初和塔马斯交谈时，情况正如我预期的那样。
What are you guys discussing?
你们在讨论什么？
Campaign.
竞选。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Every Wednesday, we are planning the next week, summarizing the last week, planning the next week and the next two weeks.
每个星期三，我们都在规划下周，总结上周，规划下周和接下来的两周。
Like, what doors to knock on and stuff like that?
比如敲哪些门之类的？
Everything.
什么都包括。
But quickly, the bizarre, surreal hoops he had to jump through in order to campaign in Hungary became clear to me. They're planning how to get their campaign literature out. Looks regular, but here's the Hungarian part. There is a policy in Hungary, Tamas is explaining to me. The postal service won't send campaign literature through the mail.
但很快，为了在匈牙利竞选而必须跳过的离奇、超现实的障碍就显现出来了。他们正在计划如何发出竞选材料。看起来很常规，但这是匈牙利特有的部分。塔马斯向我解释说，匈牙利有一项政策。邮政部门不会通过邮件发送竞选材料。
Last spring, the government changed the rule, and the Hungarian post do not handle flyers and--
去年春天，政府改变了规则，匈牙利邮政不处理传单和——
Like, campaign literature? They won't handle campaign literature? The post office?
就像，竞选材料？他们不处理竞选材料？邮局？
Yeah, nothing. Yes.
是的，什么都不管。是的。
Here's how this restriction works. It's tricky. It's diabolical. One year before this election, the postal service stopped accepting political mailings or business flyers.
这就是这个限制的运作方式。很狡猾。很邪恶。在这次选举前一年，邮政停止接受政治邮件或商业传单。
You know, sign up for this service, or vote for this guy-- you can't send that stuff through the postal service. OK. So you have to use a private company, a local delivery company-- except they won't work with Tamas.
你知道，“注册此服务”或“投票给这个人”——你不能通过邮政发送这些东西。好吧。所以你必须使用一家私人公司，一家本地配送公司——除非他们不和塔马斯合作。
And when I go there and say, I would like to pay, just please deliver my flyers, they say, sorry, I don't.
当我走到那里说，我想付钱，请派送我的传单，他们说，对不起，我不做。
And can-- what do they say--
那他们怎么说——
It's not-- it's not like it's prohibited, you know.
这不是——这不是说被禁止了，你知道。
They just say-- they just decide not--
他们只是说——他们只是决定不——
It's a shadow state, or something like this.
这是一个影子国家，或者类似的东西。
A shadow state, he calls it. It's not that Orban's party, the governing party, Fidesz, runs everything. It influences everything. Orban and his buddies tend to profit from that.
他称之为影子国家。并不是欧尔班的政党、执政党青民盟经营一切。它影响一切。欧尔班和他的伙伴倾向于从中获利。
Tamas says the local distributor guy has a contract with the local newspaper, which is currently owned by this media foundation that's run by pro-government people. And because the distributor needs that business, it refuses to work with the opposition to mail their campaign flyers.
塔马斯说，当地的分销商与当地报纸有合同，该报纸目前由一个由亲政府人士经营的媒体基金会拥有。由于分销商需要那份生意，它拒绝与反对派合作邮寄他们的竞选传单。
There's a handful of public advertising companies linked to the government in various ways that lock the opposition out. Ergo, Tamas' campaign has to deliver all their campaign mailers by hand. Billboards are another big example. It's hard for them to get billboards. It's sneaky, the shadow state.
有几家以各种方式与政府挂钩的公共广告公司将反对派拒之门外。因此，塔马斯的竞选团队必须人工投递所有竞选材料。广告牌是另一个很好的例子。他们很难拿到广告牌。这很卑鄙，影子国家。
One of the few things the opposition has been able to do is hold rallies. Some are pretty big, like an event they had in Szekszard-- Tamas' area. The prime minister candidate showed up. I saw pictures. It was a big turnout. But of course, because the local paper is owned by an Orban-friendly group--
反对派能做的少数几件事之一是举行集会。有些相当大，就像他们在塞克萨尔德——塔马斯的选区——举办的活动。总理候选人出现了。我看了照片。参加人数很多。但当然，因为当地报纸由一家欧尔班友好的集团拥有——
It never happened. It wasn't in the local newspaper, nor in the local radio, or in the television, like it never happened.
它从没发生过。当地报纸、当地电台或电视里都没有报道，就像它从未发生过一样。
There's one other thing Tamas described to me about his particular job that was surreal-- almost creepy to imagine it. It's how stifling it is inside the actual parliament. You can't do anything. Like, you really can't do anything in the minority.
塔马斯向我描述的关于他工作的另一件事是超现实的——甚至有点令人毛骨悚然。议会内部太令人窒息了。你什么也做不了。就像，作为少数派，你真的什么也做不了。
Tamas keeps showing up to work, though. The parliament building is a big, beautiful, spiky, castle-looking building-- more "Brothers Grimm" than Disney, which is regionally appropriate. What happens inside is normal parliament stuff.
不过塔马斯还是坚持去上班。议会大楼是一座又大又美、尖顶、看起来像城堡的大楼——比迪士尼更像“格林兄弟”，这在地区上很合适。里面发生的是正常的议会事务。
Tamas comes in, takes his place. He speaks out against the Orban laws, which come fast and furious. But it's like a weird Dadaist performance. There used to be a sort of C-SPAN broadcasting what was going on in there. Orban shut it down.
塔马斯走进去，回到他的位置。他公开反对欧尔班的法律，那些法律来得又快又猛。但这就像一场古怪的达达主义表演。曾经有一种类似C-SPAN的电视节目在广播那里发生的事情。欧尔班把它停了。
Television, radio, and newspapers will not report on his arguments. But he says, if he doesn't show up and say something, that's kind of like the whole democracy is throwing in the towel. There has to be debate.
电视、广播和报纸都不会报道他的论点。但他认为，如果他不出席并不发声，那就像整个民主制度在投降。必须有辩论。
If you take it away, then you take away the spirit of not just democracy, but the chance to change. It is [HUNGARIAN].
如果你把它拿走，那么你就拿走了不仅是民主的精神，还有改变的机会。这是[匈牙利语]。
Unbearable.
难以忍受。
Unbearable, what's happening in the house of parliament in Hungary these days.
难以忍受，匈牙利议会大厦里最近发生的事情。
So at the moment, it's like, you go, you debate, you say what you think, but nobody can hear it. The public can't hear it, and there's no publicity, so nobody writes about it.
所以目前，就像是，你去，你辩论，你说出你的想法，但没人能听见。公众听不见，也没有宣传，所以没人报道。
We can use our Facebook. That's it.
我们可以用Facebook。仅此而已。
Yeah.
是的。
Of course our supporters are following it, but it's, you know, inside our bubble.
当然我们的支持者在关注，但你知道，是在我们的泡沫里。
Obviously, we don't need a Viktor Orban to put ourselves so completely in our own media silos, that you never hear the argument of the other side. We have C-SPAN, we have The Washington Post running around the capital, we have Politico, telling us what's going on inside our government every day.
显然，我们不需要一个维克托·欧尔班把我们完全限制在自己的媒体泡沫中，以至于你永远听不到对方的观点。我们有C-SPAN，我们有《华盛顿邮报》在首都跑动，我们有Politico，每天告诉我们政府内部正在发生什么。
But who reads The Washington Post and Politico? The people who believe what's in it. Hungary is a similar situation. There is independent media that's not influenced by Orban, but it's mostly online, and you have to know about it to go find it. You have to want it.
但谁会读《华盛顿邮报》和Politico？相信里面内容的人。匈牙利的情况类似。有不受欧尔班影响的独立媒体，但它们大多在线，你必须知道它才能去找它。你必须想要它。
Fidesz supporters are often rural and older. They have the TV and the radio on, it's controlled by the state, and they think the opposition is lying. The new phrase in Hungarian for "fake news" is "fake news."
青民盟的支持者通常是农村和老年人。他们开着电视和收音机，它是国家控制的，他们认为反对派在撒谎。匈牙利语中对于“假新闻”的新称呼就是“fake news”（英文假新闻）。
This is the thing that's most similar, in my view, between Hungary and America-- the media situation. There, the right-wing values on radio and TV are enforced by the state. Here, we self-segregate into our own bubbles. But we also live in two different media universes.
在我看来，匈牙利和美国之间最相似的地方就是媒体环境。在那里，广播和电视上的右翼价值观是由国家强制执行的。在这里，我们自我隔离在自己的泡泡中。但我们也生活在两个不同的媒体宇宙中。
A month before election day, Russia invaded Ukraine. Hungary borders Ukraine, and refugees were pouring in. Hungarians were really scared about the war. Orban started saying the opposition wanted to send Hungarian troops to fight in Ukraine-- incredibly unpopular, also totally untrue. The state media repeated this line endlessly.
选举日前一个月，俄罗斯入侵了乌克兰。匈牙利与乌克兰接壤，难民涌入。匈牙利人对战争非常害怕。欧尔班开始说反对派想派匈牙利军队去乌克兰打仗——这极其不受欢迎，也完全是谎言。国家媒体无休止地重复这一说法。
On the other hand, Orban's so close to Putin, people in the opposition thought, this war can't help Orban. How are you feeling about things? I called Gabor a week before the election.
另一方面，欧尔班与普京如此亲近，反对派人士认为，这场战争对欧尔班没有任何帮助。你感觉如何？我在选举前一周打电话给加博尔。
I can't give you a real reason, but-- (CHUCKLING) I'm getting more and more optimistic.
我给不出真正的理由，但——（轻笑）我变得越来越乐观了。
(CHUCKLING) Wow.
（轻笑）哇。
I don't know if you could follow the latest opinion polls.
我不知道你是否关注了最新的民意调查。
Mm. No. Tell me.
嗯。不。告诉我。
They were-- no, so they were not the best.
它们——不，所以它们不是最好的。
OK.
好的。
There were some which were quite bad.
有一些相当糟糕。
None of the polls-- the more legit or the less legit-- none of them ever showed a big advantage for the opposition. But the opposition was deploying all sorts of old-fashioned ways to get the word out. There's not a big tradition in Hungary, Gabor says, of door-to-door campaigning.
没有一个民调——无论是更合法的还是不太合法的——从来没有显示反对派有大优势。但反对派正在部署各种老式方法来传播消息。加博尔说，匈牙利没有门对门竞选的大传统。
But they were doing it-- face-to-face interactions, big rallies around the country, handing out literature, holding meetings in the countryside, where media is especially limited to state propaganda. He was seeing stuff he'd never seen before-- people signing up to volunteer. Money was coming in. The opposition was richer than it had ever been.
但他们正在这样做——面对面的互动、全国各地的大型集会、发放材料、在乡村举行会议，那里的媒体尤其局限于国家宣传。他看到了他从未见过的东西——人们报名做志愿者。钱也进来了。反对派比以往任何时候都富有。
They were sharing all their lists of supporters so they had all this data they'd never had before. As Gabor went around to make his pitch, the rooms were getting fuller. When I visited, he was worried that no one believed they could win, so they wouldn't bother trying to help them win. But now, he thought, people were starting to believe it.
他们分享了他们所有的支持者名单，所以他们有了以前从未拥有的所有数据。当加博尔四处游说时，房间变得越来越满。我访问时，他担心没人相信他们能赢，所以他们不会费心去帮助他们赢。但现在，他认为人们开始相信了。
People are starting to maybe want to be part of a historic moment.
人们开始可能想要成为历史性时刻的一部分。
Yes, yes, yes. And we are far more organized than we were before. And I don't believe that it cannot be enough.
是的，是的，是的。而且我们比以前组织得好得多。我不相信这还不够。
[CROWD CHEERING]
[人群欢呼]
In Hungary's capital, a few hundred cheered as Viktor Orban headed towards his fourth consecutive term as prime minister.
在匈牙利首都，几百人欢呼着维克托·欧尔班迈向他连续第四个总理任期。
[SPEAKING HUNGARIAN]
[匈牙利语演讲]
Dear friends, he said. We've achieved a huge victory.
亲爱的朋友们，他说。我们取得了巨大的胜利。
It was over that evening, Sunday, April 3.
那天晚上，4月3日星期日，一切都结束了。
Hello, Zoe. It's Gabor.
你好，佐伊。我是加博尔。
Hi.
嗨。
How are you?
你好吗？
[SIGHS] Feeling very bad.
[叹气] 感觉很糟糕。
Oh. I don't know what to say.
哦。我不知道该说什么。
It's a disaster. Yeah. Well. It's really unbelievable.
这是一场灾难。是的。好吧。真是不可思议。
It wasn't just that Orban won, that Fidesz won. They won resoundingly. They won the 2/3 majority again, easily. When I talked to Orban spokesman about all this, he insisted the election would be fair.
不仅仅是欧尔班赢了，不仅仅是青民盟赢了。他们赢得很彻底。他们又轻易地赢得了三分之二的多数。当我向欧尔班发言人询问这一切时，他坚称选举是公平的。
But that's contradicted by facts on the ground. The wind was at Orban's back because of a lot of stuff-- these structural advantages, money advantages, gerrymandering advantages, obviously, the media.
但这与实地事实相矛盾。因为很多因素，风向偏向欧尔班——这些结构性优势、金钱优势、选区划分优势，显然还有媒体。
But even with all that, the opposition was missing voters, missing supporters. Something like 800,000 to one million voters they had counted on did not show up and vote for them. Where were they? They were voting, just not for the opposition.
但即使有这一切，反对派还是缺少选民，缺少支持者。大约有80万到100万他们指望的选民没有出现并投票给他们。他们去哪儿了？他们在投票，只是不是投给反对派。
They were Jobbik voters. The Jobbik voters probably went for Fidesz, or for this new far-far-right party, an ultranationalist, racist, anti-vaccine party, called Mi Hazánk, My Homeland. That party got a lot of new supporters, enough votes to sit-in parliament.
他们是尤比克党的选民。尤比克党的选民可能投给了青民盟，或者投给了这个新的极右政党，一个超民族主义、种族主义、反疫苗的政党，叫“我们的祖国”（Mi Hazánk）。那个政党获得了大量新支持者，足以进入议会。
Gabor says, for sure, they'll be part of the Fidesz voting bloc when they get there. Gabor was back at the socialist building with the party president. They were watching the Marki-Zay concession speech and trying to imagine the next morning.
加博尔说，当然，当他们到了那里，他们会成为青民盟投票集团的一部分。加博尔回到了与党主席在一起的社会主义大楼。他们正在观看马尔基-扎伊的让步演讲，并试图想象第二天早上。
You know, tomorrow, we have to say something to our party members and decide what we will do. So we have a kind of emergency meeting.
你知道，明天，我们必须对党员说些什么，并决定我们要做什么。所以我们有某种紧急会议。
He was expecting people to be upset. Seems like this coalition hadn't worked out.
他预计人们会很沮丧。看起来这个联盟并没有奏效。
You know, when I called my wife, she just told me that she started to pack the big suitcases.
你知道，当我打电话给我妻子时，她只是告诉我她开始打包大行李箱了。
No. [CHUCKLES]
不。[轻笑]
It's really difficult, especially, you know, with the children. If, uh, the people who are thinking just like us, who would like to follow the classical European values, have only less than 1/3 in the country, then it makes further questions.
这真的很困难，尤其是，你知道，有了孩子。如果，嗯，像我们这样思考的人，那些想要追随经典欧洲价值观的人，在这个国家只有不到三分之一，那么这就提出了进一步的问题。
Even the reporters I talked to were taken aback. Everyone had expected Orban to win, but for the election to be close. This is a huge mandate for Orban, and a signal to the rest of Europe that a lot of Europeans like Orban's politics.
连我采访的记者都感到惊讶。每个人都预料到欧尔班会赢，但认为选举会很接近。这对欧尔班来说是一个巨大的授权，也是向欧洲其他国家发出的一个信号，即许多欧洲人喜欢欧尔班的政治。
Gabor never imagined they were outnumbered this badly. That sick feeling he'd had in parliament 12 years ago-- it was back.
加博尔从没想过他们被超越得这么惨。他在12年前议会里的那种恶心感觉——又回来了。
This difference is shocking.
这种差异令人震惊。
It's funny. I expected that Gabor might castigate himself for making compromises he shouldn't have, or castigate Jobbik, or others in the coalition. They'd made a big plan, and the plan had failed. Things must not have been going as well as he thought.
有趣的是。我以为加博尔可能会因为做了他不该做的妥协而责备自己，或者责备尤比克党，或者联盟中的其他人。他们制定了一个大计划，而计划失败了。事情一定不像他想的那样顺利。
No, he told me, the parties did a great job, really campaigned hard. We finally met all of our supporters face-to-face. There just weren't enough of them.
不，他告诉我，各政党表现得很好，真的努力竞选。我们终于与我们所有的支持者面对面了。只是他们不够多。
I could read many campaign books on how to run campaigns, he said. It wasn't the campaign. Orban said over and over, if the opposition won, we were going to war in Ukraine. It wasn't true, but people believed it. Authoritarianism works, he said. They always find a way to win.
我可以阅读许多关于如何进行竞选活动的竞选书籍，他说。这不是竞选的问题。欧尔班一遍又一遍地说，如果反对派赢了，我们将去乌克兰打仗。这不是真的，但人们相信了。威权主义奏效，他说。他们总能找到获胜的方法。
Zoe Chace-- she's one of the producers of our show. Coming up-- secret recordings from inside a Russian police station that surprised even Russians. That's in a minute on Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
佐伊·蔡斯——她是我们的节目制片人之一。接下来——俄罗斯警察局内的秘密录音，甚至让俄罗斯人都感到惊讶。一分钟后，我们的节目在芝加哥公共广播电台继续播出。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today on our show, "Do Not Go Gentle"-- stories of people doing whatever they can think of to fight back, to resist, to say no, to what fate seems to have in store for them. We've arrived at Act Two of our program. Act Two, Putin's on Our Side.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天在我们的节目中，“不要温和地走进那个良夜”——关于人们为了反击、为了抵抗、为了对命运似乎为他们准备的一切说“不”而竭尽所能的故事。我们来到了节目的第二幕。第二幕，普京站在我们这边。
So the laws on reporting the news in Russia have changed since the invasion of Ukraine. You may have heard about this. If you're a media outlet in Russia, you cannot use the word "war" to characterize the Russian invasion of Ukraine. You have to call it a "special military operation."
俄罗斯报道新闻的法律在入侵乌克兰后发生了变化。你可能听说过。如果你是俄罗斯的媒体，你不能使用“战争”这个词来描述俄罗斯对乌克兰的入侵。你必须称之为“特别军事行动”。
You can't talk about Ukrainian civilians being bombed. Novaya Gazeta is one of the oldest independent newspapers in Russia. Its editor-in-chief won the Nobel Peace Prize last year.
你不能谈论乌克兰平民被轰炸。《新报》是俄罗斯最古老的独立报纸之一。它的主编去年获得了诺贝尔和平奖。
And when the war began, it didn't follow those new rules from the Russian government. It did straight accurate reporting. Then, the Russian Ministry of Defense sent a written warning saying all their news was fake news.
战争开始时，它没有遵循俄罗斯政府的新规定。它进行了直接、准确的报道。然后，俄罗斯国防部发来书面警告，称他们所有的新闻都是假新闻。
They couldn't keep operating the way they had. They could be shut down, which left the paper to figure out what to do, how to report on the war. And what they came up with was pretty ingenious. One of our producers, Robyn Semien, tells the story.
他们无法继续按照以前的方式运作。他们可能会被关闭，这让报纸不得不弄清楚该做什么，如何报道战争。他们想出的方法相当巧妙。我们的一位制片人，罗宾·塞米恩，讲述了这个故事。
Reporting in Russia has all sorts of perils. Since Putin has been in power, Novaya Gazeta has seen six of its journalists murdered by methods that include poison and gunshots at close range. They've had other journalists threatened. And it was clear that the new rules on reporting on Ukraine and the warning the paper got from the government would require new tactics.
在俄罗斯报道有各种危险。自普京掌权以来，《新报》目睹了六名记者被谋杀，手段包括中毒和近距离枪击。他们有其他记者受到威胁。很明显，有关乌克兰报道的新规定以及报纸从政府那里收到的警告，将需要新的策略。
So the first thing the paper did-- this was in early March. They removed any story they'd run that potentially broke the law, like the one called "Putin Invades Ukraine," or "There's No Justification for this War." Or the cover story, "Russia is Bombing Ukraine," was gone, taken down. I talked to Nikita Kondratiev, the Head of News there, about this pause. Nikita said, they had to.
所以报纸做的第一件事——这是在三月初。他们删除了他们发布的任何可能触犯法律的故事，比如那篇叫“普京入侵乌克兰”，或者“这场战争没有正当理由”。或者封面故事，“俄罗斯正在轰炸乌克兰”，都被删除了。我采访了那里的新闻主管尼基塔·孔德拉季耶夫，谈到了这次暂停。尼基塔说，他们必须这样做。
Stop printing the news for a while, just to understand how to exist in this new reality.
停止打印新闻一段时间，只是为了理解如何在这种新现实中存在。
Nikita had watched as just this year, other independent news outlets, one by one, had succumbed to the pressure and closed, fled, or been taken over by state media.
尼基塔目睹了就在今年，其他独立新闻媒体一个个屈服于压力而关闭、逃亡或被国家媒体接管。
Dozhd is "rain" in Russian, so TV Rain-- they--
Dozhd在俄语里是“雨”的意思，所以“雨电视台”——他们——
First, TV Rain shut down. Meduza's reporters fled the country. Nikita knows this by heart. There are others.
首先，雨电视台关闭了。Meduza的记者逃离了该国。尼基塔对这些如数家珍。还有其他人。
There is a media outlet called MediaZona. They also fled the country. Who else? The oldest liberal radio station called Echo of Moscow, Ekho Moskvy, closed. Now, their radio frequency is now occupied by state propaganda radio, called Sputnik.
有一个叫MediaZona的媒体。他们也逃离了该国。还有谁？最古老的自由电台叫“莫斯科回声”（Ekho Moskvy），关闭了。现在，他们的广播频率被国家宣传电台“卫星”（Sputnik）占领。
Novaya Gazeta was the last major independent media outlet in the country, and they'd stopped reporting on the war to figure out their next move.
《新报》是国内最后一家主要的独立媒体，他们停止了报道战争以决定下一步行动。
Just days into that pause, a story fell into Nikita's lap that would reshape the paper's entire approach to their coverage. He was sent audio recordings of police brutality. The recordings had been made secretly by Russian civilians-- women, specifically-- many from a feminist anti-war group, who'd been out protesting the Russian invasion one afternoon in early March and were taken into police custody. Hours later, Nikita listened to it.
在暂停的几天里，一个故事落到了尼基塔的手中，这将重塑报纸的整个报道方式。他收到了关于警察暴力的录音。录音是由俄罗斯平民——具体来说是女性——秘密制作的，她们中的许多人来自一个反战女权组织，某天三月初下午她们去抗议俄罗斯的入侵，随后被警方拘留。几小时后，尼基塔听了它。
It was during the night, and I just had to wake some of my colleagues up to help me with this recording. That's not any news for us that people are tortured in police departments and so on. But just before the 8th of March, before the International Women's Day and on a peaceful protest like that, policemen tried to torture and beat young women students-- that was shocking.
那是半夜，我不得不叫醒我的一些同事来帮我处理这个录音。人们在警察部门受折磨等等对我们来说不是什么新闻。但在3月8日国际妇女节之前，在那样一场和平抗议中，警察试图折磨和殴打年轻女学生——那很令人震惊。
It was shocking to them, because peaceful protests are legal in Russia. And up till now, there wasn't such blatant evidence of this kind of misogyny and violence directed at young women, college students, feminists.
这让他们感到震惊，因为在俄罗斯和平抗议是合法的。直到现在，还没有如此明显的证据表明这种针对年轻女性、女大学生、女权主义者的厌女症和暴力。
What was the discussion inside your newsroom about the importance of running this?
你们新闻编辑部内部关于发布这一内容的重要性的讨论是什么？
Their reaction was just shit, fuck, that shit is fucked up. That was the reaction.
他们的反应就是“该死”、“妈的”、“那破事儿真糟透了”。就是那样的反应。
(CHUCKLING) OK.
（轻笑）好的。
(CHUCKLING) Nothing else.
（轻笑）没别的。
Yes. It wasn't a high-minded debate.
是的。那不是一场高尚的辩论。
Yeah, yeah. The point is that this is an important story. We have to report it.
是的，是的。重点是这是一个重要的故事。我们必须报道它。
Important enough, they decided to start publishing again. This was Novaya Gazeta's first big multi-part story. It is explicitly not set in Ukraine or talking to Ukrainians about the war, but instead, about Russian resistance to the same war-- the one they had to shut up about.
重要到他们决定重新开始出版。《新报》的第一篇大型多部分故事。它明确不是设定在乌克兰，也不是谈论乌克兰人的战争，而是关于俄罗斯对同一场战争的抵抗——那场他们被迫闭嘴的战争。
I'm going to play you some of these recordings, because this was news, even for veteran journalists like Nikita, who've seen and reported on corrupt and shockingly dark stuff. I also want to play these, because in them, you can hear the variety of ways that the protesters deal with the cops.
我打算给你们听一些这些录音，因为这对即使像尼基塔这样目睹并报道过腐败和令人震惊的黑暗事件的资深记者来说也是新闻。我也想播放这些，因为在里面，你可以听到抗议者对付警察的各种方式。
Their personalities are so present. They don't cower. In fact, they really do the opposite. They assert who they are in the face of real violence. A quick warning-- this probably isn't right for kids to be listening to.
她们的个性如此鲜明。她们不屈服。事实上，她们确实做了相反的事。她们在真正的暴力面前主张自己的身份。一个小警告——这对孩子们来说可能不适合听。
[INDISTINCT RUSSIAN SPEECH]
[模糊的俄语演讲]
Audio is hard to hear and in Russian. But the protester has just been asked for her name and gives it-- Aleksandra Kaluzhskikh. Aleksandra was one of 30 protesters brought from a square in Moscow to this precinct in Bratayevo that day, and she anticipated making this recording.
音频很难听清楚，是俄语的。但抗议者刚刚被问及她的名字并说出了它——亚历山德拉·卡卢日斯基赫。亚历山德拉是那天被从莫斯科广场带到布拉塔耶沃这个分局的30名抗议者之一，她预料到会录下这个记录。
She brought two phones with her to the precinct-- one old broken one, a decoy for the police, who actually do take the phone and hurl it at the wall, and another phone she hid in her pocket to make this recording.
她带了两部手机到分局——一部旧的、破的，是个诱饵，给警察看的，他们确实拿走了手机并把它扔在了墙上；另一部手机她藏在口袋里，录下了这段记录。
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[俄语演讲]
She's asked, where do you live?
她被问到：你住在哪？
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[俄语演讲]
Aleksandra says, um, how do I say it? Well, see, the 51st. The 51st is the right to remain silent in Russia. This makes the male officer angry. And he hits her-- the first of many in the recording. You can hear the muffled sound. It's like a crack.
亚历山德拉说，嗯，我该怎么说呢？嗯，看，第51条。第51条是俄罗斯沉默的权利。这让男警官很生气。他打了她——录音中多次殴打的第一次。你可以听到闷响。就像一声脆响。
[SMACK]
[啪]
Next time, it'll be even harder, he says before hitting her again.
下次会更狠，他说完又打了她一次。
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[俄语演讲]
Lots of this audio is odd, because it's filled with this kind of exposition by the police. Something happens, and before Aleksandra can do it herself, the police narrate through it, like they're performing for a recording they don't know they're making.
这段录音里有很多地方很奇怪，因为它充满了警察的这种自我阐述。发生了什么事，而在亚历山德拉自己能做之前，警察就一直在叙述，好像他们在为一段他们不知道自己正在制作的录音进行表演一样。
Like, one officer says out loud, what is your goal? This will only get exponentially worse for you. And Aleksandra asked, point blank, are you threatening me? And the officer, as if he is reading lines from a bad script, says, yes, I'm threatening you. I'm threatening you with physical violence.
比如，一名警官大声说，你的目标是什么？这只会让你情况变得呈指数级地糟。而亚历山德拉直截了当地问：你在威胁我吗？那名警官，好像在读糟糕剧本里的台词，说：是的，我在威胁你。我用身体暴力威胁你。
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[俄语演讲]
When the officers don't narrate their own actions, Aleksandra does. And she tries to appeal to their sense of reason. She asks one female officer, is this normal? You're fine with this, watching this happen?
当警官不叙述他们自己的行为时，亚历山德拉就自己叙述。她试图诉诸他们的理性。她问一名女警官，这正常吗？你对此没意见吗，看着这一切发生？
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[俄语演讲]
Perfectly fine, the female officer responds. Another officer erupts. Look at yourself! Fuck. Your fucking tits, hanging like goddamn utters. Look at yourself, fucking monkey.
完全没意见，那名女警官回答。另一名警官爆发了。看看你自己！该死。你那该死的乳房，像母牛的奶头一样下垂。看看你自己，你这该死的猴子。
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[俄语演讲]
Place of study? The woman officer asks, like nothing happened. The officer's language is so obscene, it's embarrassing to quote it. Another protester told me she was more surprised by that-- by their language-- than by being hit.
学习地点？女警官问，好像什么都没发生。那名警官的语言非常淫秽，引用它都让人难堪。另一名抗议者告诉我，她对那——对他们的语言——感到比被打更惊讶。
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[俄语演讲]
Female officer-- how did you find out about the protest?
女警官——你是怎么知道这次抗议的？
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[俄语演讲]
Aleksandra-- ugh, I refuse to answer. The 51st.
亚历山德拉——呃，我拒绝回答。第51条。
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[俄语演讲]
Female officer-- you're all fucked in the head. All of you are fucked up.
女警官——你们脑子都有毛病。你们都烂透了。
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[俄语演讲]
Aleksandra-- a man is beating me in front of you, and I'm the one who's fucked up?
亚历山德拉——一个男人当着你的面打我，而我是那个烂透了的人？
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[俄语演讲]
Female officer-- yeah, yeah. Listening, I worried what these officers would do if they discovered Aleksandra was recording them. They're such hotheads.
女警官——是啊，是啊。听着，我很担心如果这些警察发现亚历山德拉在录音他们会做什么。他们是那种热血沸腾的人。
Nikita thinks, though he isn't sure, that some of the police were probably Center E Police, a specialized unit who are known for their brutal interrogation tactics. Center E is the center for combating extremism. In the past, extremism meant terrorists. Today, it means protesters.
尼基塔认为，尽管他不确定，其中一些警察可能是E中心警察，这是一个专门的单位，以残酷的审讯手段著称。E中心是打击极端主义中心。过去，极端主义意味着恐怖分子。今天，它意味着抗议者。
We contacted the precinct in Bratayevo about this. They said, no comment. One officer in the precinct with Aleksandra makes it very clear who is behind his disdain. He tells her--
我们就此联系了布拉塔耶沃的分局。他们说，无可奉告。亚历山德拉所在分局的一名警官非常清楚他的蔑视背后是谁。他告诉她——
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[俄语演讲]
Putin told us to fuck all of you up, fucking dumb fucks. That's it. Putin's on our side. You're the enemies of the Russian people, OK? Fucking enemies of the state.
普京叫我们揍扁你们所有人，该死的蠢货。就是这样。普京站在我们这边。你们是俄罗斯人民的敌人，好吗？该死的国家敌人。
[ALEKSANDRA SIGHS]
[亚历山德拉叹气]
Aleksandra sighs.
亚历山德拉叹了口气。
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[俄语演讲]
We're going to fucking kill you, OK? And that'll be it, finished. And then, they'll give us a prize for it, too. Putin's on our side. That quote is the headline of the entire Novaya Gazeta series, in big bold letters, white font on black background-- "Putin is on Our Side."
我们要杀了你们，好吗？那样就结束了，完成了。然后，他们甚至会为此奖励我们。普京站在我们这边。那句引语是整个《新报》系列的标题，用粗体大字，黑底白字——“普京站在我们这边”。
It's kind of a funny lead headline for the opposition paper to use the day it starts publishing again. If you don't read the story, all you see is, Novaya Gazeta, looking down, whistling, hands behind its back, the most obedient Putin-friendly paper ever.
对于反对派报纸来说，在重新开始出版的第一天使用这种头条新闻真是有点滑稽。如果你不读这个故事，你所看到的只是《新报》在低头、吹口哨、背着手，看起来像是有史以来最服从普京的报纸。
I talked to another protester, who I'll call Sofia. Sofia was in the precinct the same day as Aleksandra. Sofia and Aleksandra first crossed paths in the police van.
我采访了另一名抗议者，我称她为索菲亚。索菲亚和亚历山德拉在同一天在分局。索菲亚和亚历山德拉第一次相遇是在警车里。
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[俄语演讲]
That's Sofia's voice. She wasn't recording in the precinct, but at some point, she and Aleksandra get moved to a narrow room with four small tables, so she ended up on Aleksandra's recording.
那是索菲亚的声音。她在分局里没有录音，但在某个时刻，她和亚历山德拉被转移到一个有四张小桌子的狭窄房间，所以她最终出现在了亚历山德拉的录音里。
She said she wasn't afraid of her intake officer. He seemed OK-- conversational, even. Unlike Aleksandra, Sofia was pretty compliant and agreeable. When an officer asked for her passport, she gave it.
她说她并不害怕她的收押警官。他看起来还行——甚至还能交谈。与亚历山德拉不同，索菲亚非常顺从和随和。当警官要她的护照时，她给了。
Where Sofia pushed back-- the police wanted to take her picture, and she knew that was illegal. Besides, they had her passport with her picture in it. So she said no to having her picture taken.
索菲亚反抗的地方——警察想给她拍照，而她知道那是违法的。此外，他们有她的护照，上面有她的照片。所以她拒绝被拍照。
Yeah, of course! I know my rights! I live in Russia, yeah, but I know my rights.
是的，当然！我知道我的权利！我住在俄罗斯，是的，但我知道我的权利。
Sofia told me she was assaulted, too-- by a different officer, in a small room down a hallway, where there were a few other police in plainclothes. One, dressed in all black, dumped water on her and hit her.
索菲亚告诉我她也被袭击了——被另一个警官，在走廊尽头的一个小房间里，那里还有几个便衣警察。其中一个全身黑衣，往她身上倒水并打了她。
They were beating me on my head, and also, they choked me.
他们打我的头，而且还掐我。
Choked you?
掐你？
Yeah, with a bag, with a plastic bag.
是的，用袋子，用塑料袋。
Over your head? Like, they put a plastic bag over your head?
套在头上？就像，他们把一个塑料袋套在你头上？
Yeah, over my head.
是的，套在我的头上。
Oh, no. I'm sorry.
哦，不。我很抱歉。
Yeah, I know. It's scary to hear. I know. I understand.
是的，我知道。听到很可怕。我知道。我理解。
Again, this was news, even to the journalists at Novaya Gazeta-- that women protesters, college students at that, would be treated this way. By the end of her recording, Aleksandra had been hit so often, she'd begun crying.
同样，这甚至对《新报》的记者来说都是新闻——女抗议者，甚至是女大学生，会受到这种对待。到录音结束时，亚历山德拉被打得太频繁了，她开始哭泣。
[ALEKSANDRA CRYING ON RECORDING]
[录音中亚历山德拉哭泣]
Sofia was resigned in a different way. She'd become more compliant, more agreeable, telling them--
索菲亚以另一种方式认命了。她变得更顺从、更随和，告诉他们——
Where I am studying, and where I'm living, and also my phone number-- I gave them only my phone numbers, so they stopped.
我在哪里学习，住在哪，还有我的电话号码——我只给了他们我的电话号码，所以他们停手了。
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[俄语演讲]
I will be very well-behaved, she says. And then--
我会表现得很好的，她说。然后——
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[俄语演讲]
Do you want me to tell you my name again? Or no? Only one of the seven protesters in the Novaya Gazeta series wasn't assaulted. There's a morbid equality to how they're treated, no matter how they acted. Take Aleksandra. She's stoic, recording like a technician, collecting evidence.
你想让我再说一次我的名字吗？还是不用？《新报》系列里的七名抗议者中，只有一个没有受到袭击。无论她们表现如何，她们受到的待遇有一种病态的平等。看看亚历山德拉。她是坚忍的，像个技术员一样录音，收集证据。
Sofia killed them with kindness. It didn't help. I want to play one last recording. It's my favorite, if you can have such a thing. Because the protester is crazy-daring. She does not care. It's the subtext of her entire exchange.
索菲亚用善良杀死了他们。没用。我想放最后一段录音。这是我最喜欢的，如果可以这样说的话。因为抗议者非常大胆。她不在乎。这是她整个对话的潜台词。
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[俄语演讲]
Marina Morozova is a grad student studying neuroscience. She did not have two phones. She just had one phone, which she expected the police to take.
玛丽娜·莫罗佐娃是一名研究神经科学的研究生。她没有两部手机。她只有一部手机，她预计警察会拿走它。
For some reason, they didn't do that. I don't know why, and nobody knows why. Just because maybe they were just fearless and stupid.
出于某种原因，他们没有那样做。我不知道为什么，也没人知道为什么。可能只是因为她们无畏而愚蠢。
Marina's recording is particularly jarring, because she's as bubbly and unconcerned about being in police custody as she is being interviewed. She called the police "stupid" and "not very clever" a lot, talking to me, which surprised me, because I figured, it just doesn't seem safe to be badmouthing any Russian authority right now.
玛丽娜的录音特别令人不安，因为她在被警方拘留期间和被采访时一样，活跃且毫不在意。她称警察“愚蠢”和“不太聪明”，这让我感到惊讶，因为我想，现在说任何俄罗斯当局的坏话似乎都不安全。
When the police officer's searching through your phone and you know that you're recording, are you nervous?
当警察搜查你的手机，而你知道你在录音时，你紧张吗？
I was smiling a lot, and it was very-- it made them very uncomfortable, because they saw me smiling, and they didn't understand why. And I didn't-- I cannot say to them why I am smiling when they ask me.
我一直在笑，而且这非常——这让他们非常不舒服，因为他们看到我在笑，而不明白为什么。我不能——我无法告诉他们，当他们问我时，我为什么要笑。
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[俄语演讲]
The officer asks, what are you smiling about?
那名警官问，你在笑什么？
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[俄语演讲]
What's so funny? Should we take you to the crazy house? Are you sick or something?
有什么好笑的？我们应该把你带到精神病院吗？你生病了吗还是什么？
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[俄语演讲]
A woman officer says, you are the one who looks stupid right now, not us.
一名女警官说，现在看起来愚蠢的是你，不是我们。
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[俄语演讲]
Marina says, well, that's what you think.
玛丽娜说，嗯，那是你以为的。
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[俄语演讲]
She provokes them, dodges their questions. How did you hear about the rally? A female officer asks. What rally? I don't know what rally you're talking about, Marina says.
她激怒他们，躲避他们的问题。你是怎么知道这次集会的？一名女警官问。什么集会？我不知道你在说什么集会，玛丽娜说。
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[俄语演讲]
A male officer asks, you're trying to play dumb now. You were just walking around the center of Moscow for no reason? Another officer says, we've never once detained a person for nothing before.
男警官问，你现在想装傻是吗？你只是在莫斯科中心无缘无故地走来走去？另一名警官说，我们从来没有无缘无故扣留过一个人。
We always have a reason. We have never not had a reason. Everybody gets nabbed for something, and then they are always yelling and screaming about it.
我们总是有理由。我们从来没有过没有理由的情况。每个人都会因为某事被抓，然后他们总是对此大喊大叫。
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[俄语演讲]
Yes, yes, I know, Marina shoots back. The police are doing a great job.
是的，是的，我知道，玛丽娜反击道。警察干得好。
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[俄语演讲]
You're really antagonizing them.
你真的在激怒他们。
Actually, I wasn't antagonizing, I think. I just said, like, double messages. [CHUCKLES] It was just double message. I think maybe they just-- they even didn't understand this joke.
其实，我不认为我在激怒。我只是说，像，双重信息。[轻笑] 这只是双重信息。我想也许他们只是——他们甚至没听懂这个笑话。
The joke being, the police are doing a great job. Marina knew about people being beaten. She was in a group chat with other protesters who had been interrogated ahead of her.
那个笑话就是：警察干得很好。玛丽娜知道有人被打。她在一个与其他在审讯室里她之前就被审讯过的抗议者的群聊中。
And your mentality is, I know what's going to happen, so I feel prepared. That's what you're thinking?
你的心态是，我知道会发生什么，所以我感觉准备好了。你是在这么想吗？
Actually, I thought that I'm more prepared than I actually was.
其实，我以为我比实际情况准备得更充分。
We listened to her recording together. And the moment where Marina realizes she may be in over her head comes on the heels of yet another dig at police.
我们一起听了她的录音。玛丽娜意识到她可能应付不来的那一刻，紧接着又是对警察的一次嘲讽。
I like this moment a lot, and my friends like this moment.
我非常喜欢这一刻，我的朋友们也喜欢这一刻。
Which moment? Which moment?
哪一刻？哪一刻？
6 minutes 42 seconds--
6分42秒——
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[俄语演讲]
Female officer asks, what college? Hurry up and tell us. Marina-- why do you need to know?
女警官问，哪个学院？快点告诉我们。玛丽娜——你为什么要问这个？
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[俄语演讲]
Are you actually surprised? The male officer asks. The female officer says, I want to apply there. Marina says, I don't think you'll get in.
你真的很惊讶吗？男警官问。女警官说，我想申请那个。玛丽娜说，我认为你进不去。
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[俄语演讲]
Things escalate from there. Marina says the officer kicked her, then unholstered his gun. He waved it at her head.
事情从那里升级了。玛丽娜说警官踢了她，然后掏出了枪。他对着她的头挥舞。
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[俄语演讲]
Ouch!
哎哟！
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[俄语演讲]
It didn't look like he had the safety on, or you were worried that he didn't have the safety.
他看起来不像是开了保险，或者你担心他没有开保险。
I wasn't sure that gun was on safe, and I wasn't sure that there could not be some accident. And it was really scary for me. The moment with the gun-- I was prepared to be beaten, but I wasn't prepared for the gun. Because he could just make a mistake, and it was scary.
我不确定那把枪有没有开保险，我也不确定会不会发生意外。那真的让我很害怕。拿枪的那一刻——我准备好被打，但我没准备好面对枪。因为他可能犯个错误，那很可怕。
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[俄语演讲]
(CRYING) [SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
（哭泣）[俄语演讲]
Marina's saying, you're not even a man, you know that?
玛丽娜说，你甚至都不是个男人，你知道吗？
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[俄语演讲]
Yeah, I'm a fucking beast, he says. And you're not a fucking woman. You're just an imbecile. I ought to blow your brains out, you piece of shit. You're fucking scum.
是的，我是个该死的野兽，他说。你根本不是个女人。你只是个白痴。我应该打爆你的头，你这堆垃圾。你这该死的渣滓。
Within weeks of that afternoon at the precinct, Vladimir Putin gave a speech classifying Russians into two categories-- true patriots, and pro-West scum and traders, who should be spit out like gnats, he said, cleansed from society. Marina said she heard it, especially the part about scum and traitors. And she knew he was talking about her, and she felt bad. Things are getting worse, she said, for all Russians.
在那天下午在分局之后几周，弗拉基米尔·普京发表了演讲，将俄罗斯人分为两类——真正的爱国者，以及亲西方的渣滓和叛徒，他建议应该像驱赶小虫子一样把他们清理出社会。玛丽娜说她听到了，尤其是关于渣滓和叛徒的那部分。她知道他在说她，她感到很糟糕。事情越来越糟，她说，对于所有俄罗斯人来说。
So this story in Novaya Gazeta became a model for other stories for how to talk about the war without getting shut down. They talked to mothers whose sons were captured in Ukraine, and covered funerals of fallen soldiers from small Russian towns. One of their more daring attempts-- Nikita calls it "the golden one"-- was to send one of their star reporters to the front lines.
所以《新报》的这个故事成了其他故事谈论战争而不会被关闭的范本。他们采访了儿子在乌克兰被俘的母亲，并报道了小俄罗斯城镇阵亡士兵的葬礼。他们更大胆的尝试之一——尼基塔称之为“金牌报道”——是派一名明星记者前往前线。
Nikita said, they thought since everything the reporter described she'd seen herself with her own eyes, the report couldn't be considered false information. But it didn't work. They had to take that one down. I talked to Nikita about this in mid-March.
尼基塔说，他们想，既然记者描述的一切都是她亲眼所见，报道就不应该被视为虚假信息。但没用。他们不得不把那篇撤下。我在三月中旬和尼基塔谈到了这一点。
Have there been moments when you thought that your paper-- that Novaya Gazeta might be shut down? How often are you having that thought?
有没有那么一刻你觉得你的报纸——《新报》可能会被关闭？你多久会有这种想法？
Once a month. Once a month, our editor-in-chief, Mr. Muratov, approaches us and says, I think it's time to close the paper. But it never happens.
一个月一次。每个月，我们的主编，穆拉托夫先生，会走过来跟我们说，我认为是时候关门了。但它从来没发生过。
Like, it exists thirty years already. And every month, someone threatens us, someone tries to kill us, and we are still working. I think that's a miracle.
就像，它已经存在三十年了。每个月，有人威胁我们，有人试图杀了我们，而我们还在工作。我认为那是个奇迹。
Why do you think you haven't been forced to close yet?
为什么你认为你们还没被迫关闭？
We do not know why the government haven't shut us down yet. We have no freaking idea why this is not happening. Every morning, we wake up, and we check our website.
我们不知道为什么政府还没关掉我们。我们根本不知道为什么没发生这种情况。每天早上，我们醒来，检查我们的网站。
And every morning, we are wondering. We have no idea. Maybe it's the Nobel Prize. Maybe Mr. Putin reads us in the evenings, I hope, and he just did not want to lose his favorite newspaper. [CHUCKLES] I don't know. Really, we have no idea.
每天早上，我们都在想。我们不知道。也许是因为诺贝尔奖。也许普京先生晚上读我们，我希望，他只是不想失去他最喜欢的报纸。[轻笑] 我不知道。真的，我们一点头绪都没有。
The procedure for shutting down a media outlet in Russia is this-- a federal agency, a media watchdog, sends you a warning in writing. If you get two or more of these in a year, you can lose your reporting license. Novaya Gazeta got two warnings within days-- for not properly identifying a foreign non-profit organization in their reporting.
在俄罗斯关闭媒体的程序是这样的——联邦机构，一个媒体监管机构，书面给你发警告。如果你一年内收到两次或多次，你可能会失去报道执照。《新报》几天内就收到了两次警告——因为在报道中没有正确识别一家外国非营利组织。
The warnings, Nikita said, were something exceptional, in the sense that normally, they'd just be fined for a small mistake like that. These warnings didn't even bother to say which article got it wrong. The first warning was on March 22, the same day editor-in-chief Dmitry Muratov announced he'd be auctioning his Nobel Prize and giving the proceeds to Ukraine.
尼基塔说，这些警告非同寻常，因为通常情况下，他们只会因为那样的小错误被罚款。这些警告甚至懒得说明是哪篇文章出错了。第一次警告是在3月22日，也就是主编德米特里·穆拉托夫宣布将拍卖他的诺贝尔奖并将收益捐给乌克兰的那一天。
The theory is, Putin's people didn't like that. But please remember, Nikita tells me, it's just a theory. On Monday, March 28, the paper stopped publishing news stories. "We are suspending work," they posted online-- and in smaller writing, a promise to readers-- to continue reporting after the end of the, quote, "special operation" on the territory in Ukraine.
理论是，普京的人不喜欢那样。但请记住，尼基塔告诉我，这只是一个理论。3月28日星期一，该报停止发布新闻故事。“我们正在暂停工作，”他们在网上发布了消息——并用较小的字体向读者承诺——在乌克兰领土上的“特别行动”结束后继续报道。
Robyn Semien is one of the producers of our show.
罗宾·塞米恩是我们的节目制片人之一。
[MUSIC - "RAGE" BY THE JERKS]
[音乐 - The Jerks的“Rage”]
Our program was produced today by Diane Wu. The people who put together today's program include Chris Benderev, Susan Burton, Ben Calhoun, Zoe Chace, Dana Chivvis, Sean Cole, Michael Comite, Aviva DeKornfeld, Seth Lind, Michelle Navarro, Stowe Nelson, Katherine Rae Mondo, Will Peischel, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp, Laura Starcheski, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney, and Julie Whitaker.
我们今天的节目由戴安·吴制作。制作今天节目的人员包括克里斯·本德雷夫、苏珊·伯顿、本·卡尔霍恩、佐伊·蔡斯、达娜·奇维斯、肖恩·科尔、迈克尔·科米特、阿维瓦·德科恩菲尔德、塞思·林德、米歇尔·纳瓦罗、斯托·尼尔森、凯瑟琳·雷·蒙多、威尔·佩舍尔、罗宾·塞米恩、艾丽莎·希普、劳拉·斯塔切斯基、克里斯托弗·斯韦塔拉、马特·蒂尔尼和朱莉·惠特克。
Our managing editor is Sarah Abdurrahman, our senior editor is David Kestenbaum, our executive editor is Emanuele Berry. Our field producer in Hungary, Mate Halmos; Hungarian interpretation and translation by Anna Klaniczay, Ezster Farkas, and Vera Bakonyi-Tánczos; Russian interpretation and translation by Bela Shayevich.
我们的主编是莎拉·阿卜杜拉赫曼，高级编辑是戴维·凯斯滕鲍姆，执行编辑是埃马努埃莱·贝里。我们在匈牙利的现场制片人，马特·哈尔莫斯；匈牙利语口译和翻译由安娜·克拉尼恰伊、埃兹斯特·法尔卡斯和维拉·巴科尼-坦乔斯完成；俄语口译和翻译由贝拉·沙耶维奇完成。
Thanks also today to Mark Krotov at N+1, Calum Nicholson, Danielle Elliot, Andrej [INAUDIBLE], Zoltan Fleck, Andras Lederer, Rita Bolla, Marton Gyongyosi, Balint Ruff, Zoltan Feher, Anita Komuves, Ábel Bojár, Agnes Urban, Adam Gyurcsik, Zoltan Kovacs, Sandar Lederer, Kelefa Sanneh, Kim Scheppele, Katalin Rózsa, Zoltán Rácz, András Máhr, and Nora Schultz.
今天还要感谢N+1的马克·克罗托夫、卡勒姆·尼科尔森、丹妮尔·埃利奥特、安德烈·[听不清]、佐尔坦·弗莱克、安德拉斯·莱德勒、丽塔·博拉、马顿·金吉奥西、巴林特·鲁夫、佐尔坦·费赫尔、安妮塔·科穆韦斯、阿贝尔·博亚尔、阿格内斯·厄本、亚当·久尔奇克、佐尔坦·科瓦奇、桑达尔·莱德勒、凯莱法·萨内、金·谢佩尔、卡塔琳·罗扎、佐尔坦·拉茨、安德拉斯·马尔和诺拉·舒尔茨。
Our website-- ThisAmericanLife.org, where you can stream our archive of over 750 episodes for absolutely free. Also, there's videos, there's lists of favorite shows, if you're looking for something to listen to. There's tons of other stuff there. Again-- ThisAmericanLife.org.
我们的网站——ThisAmericanLife.org，在那里你可以免费流媒体播放我们超过750集的节目归档。此外，还有视频、最喜爱节目列表，如果你想找点东西听的话。上面还有很多其他东西。再说一遍——ThisAmericanLife.org。
This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia, who told me this piece of gossip this week. I don't know if you've heard this one. He told me the word, equality, has taken a lover of the same sex.
《美国生活》由PRX（公共广播交易所）分发给公共广播电台。像往常一样，感谢我们节目的联合创始人托里·马拉蒂亚先生，他这周告诉我这个八卦。不知道你有没有听说过。他告诉我“平等”这个词找了个同性伴侣。
The word, equality, is a little bit gay.
“平等”这个词有点太同性恋了。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
[MUSIC - "RAGE" BY THE JERKS]
[音乐 - The Jerks的“Rage”]